valentina hello how are you
jane and jose are neighbours in reading
and they're sponsoring neighbours
alexandra and valentina from kiev
but this is as close as they've got how
is
warm yeah their hospitality is on hold
while the families wait for visas it's a
good idea to get such opportunity to go
to your country
to
to try to start a normal life but uh
this process must be
quicker much more quicker okay it's be
maybe some days but not weeks not months
it's too long it's so too long for
people who are now in ukraine they
applied for visas over two weeks ago but
so far only one's been approved
so i'll show you up here where's a nice
big room that they're going to stay in
with everything ready in reading it's
frustrating too for host families two
beds for the two boys that are going to
come okay uh we've got bed for mom as
well they're in a country that they are
not used to
they're waiting there's no news the boys
are getting distressed
because they're obviously in
limbo um and it's just really difficult
day on day not knowing what's happening
and knowing that the space is here but
there's nobody using it and you're ready
to take them absolutely
nearly 80 000 ukrainians have applied
for visas with forty thousand 900
granted
so far 12 000 people have arrived in the
uk
just 1200 of them through the
sponsorship scheme
the government admits it's taking time i
know that people are disappointed with
the progress of the of the visa regime
the home secretary was out this week
expressing her frustration and regret
that it hasn't been quicker but we are
motoring now labour says the delays are
a disgrace i do not understand why
prissy patel is so failing to get a grip
on this ministers and officials have
both admitted that they can do them
really quickly that's not what's holding
things up it's not the security checks
it's the fact that they've added huge
amounts of bureaucracy that they've
never got a grip of this
can you see this is the house they're
desperate to arrive but they're stuck
and stranded with their safety hampered
by red tape and rules i hope to see you
very soon yes okay
yes us too laura bundock sky news in
reading